I'm grandma I'm the co-owner of politics
and frozen along with my wife listen
Muscatine and on behalf of everybody at
P and P and everybody here at it's at
six and I welcome you know we at
politics and prose really enjoy hosting
author talks in this this this truly
wonderful venue and the staff and at six
and I Esther for who is the executive
director and it was here this evening
and everybody else deserve lots of
credit and recognition for turning this
place over the past decade into such a
vibrant center of cultural life in the
Washington area so let's just give give
them all a round of applause
and in a minute we're gonna be hearing a
lot about human DNA but I just want to
take a moment to say something about
community DNA an important element of
community is having a local independent
bookstore many independent bookstores do
still exist in fact our numbers have
been growing in the past few years
recovering from years of decline thanks
in large part to support from many
people like you who continue to value
neighborhood bookstores so please when
you feel the urge to buy a book do shop
local you can get the full bookstore
experience by coming to politics and
prose and by full bookstore experience I
mean personalized service and advice
from expert booksellers as well as the
sense of discovery that comes from
browsing of physical shelves or if you
want to order online you can go straight
to our website and click on the book
that that you'd like now to to human DNA
and our great guest this evening Sid
Mukerjee
back in 2001 when the Pulitzer committee
awarded Sid the nonfiction Prize it
praised the Emperor of all maladies as
quote an elegant inquiry at once
clinical and personal well he's done it
again in his new book the gene which
tells the story of the development of
genetics by weaving science and social
history with some personal narrative
about his own relatives as Sid recalls
in the acknowledgments he was actually
so physically and mentally exhausted
after Emperor that he hadn't expected to
write another book but the gene turns
out to be a natural pairing with Emperor
a sort of prequel he calls it in that it
focuses on biological normalcy before
things get distorted into the malignancy
of cancer if you've ever wondered how
much of our lives is determined by our
genes versus how much depends
on external environmental factors you
need to read SIDS new book but don't
expect a simple answer because as you'll
hear from Sid in a minute it's
complicated a word about SIDS own past
as far back as his student days which
were just a couple of decades or so ago
he was already distinguishing himself he
attended Stanford when a Rhodes studied
immunology at Oxford then went to
Harvard Medical School today he's an
assistant professor of medicine at
Columbia University and a staff cancer
physician at Columbia's Medical Center
Sid's going to be in conversation here
this evening with someone who has
obviously made excellent use of her own
genes a Judy Woodruff
the co-anchor and managing editor of the
PBS Newshour and one of the most
accomplished journalism in television
today so please join me in welcoming
both Sid mukajee and Judy Woodruff
[Applause]
Thank You Brad cram for that very
gracious nobody's ever introduced me
before by saying good genes what you
have separately we're talking about my
blue jeans I guess thank you if you were
captivated by the emperor of all
maladies you will be more than
captivated by the gene thank you for
saying that and intimate history I feel
like my mic is a little bit loud I'm
gonna speak softly said that there's so
many things so many ways I'd like to
begin but but I think hearing your
personal story about why after you had
completed the the years you had worked
on the book about cancer and as we just
heard from Brad you said you were
exhausted by that but then something
else was going on in your mind about
your own family and you write about that
in a in a way that just pulls every
reader in and the very beginning of the
book what happened I mean what was going
on in your life that caused you to even
think about writing this so
interestingly I think iíve conceived of
the gene and I didn't think of it as
because that's the name of the book but
I thought about the gene for a long time
simply because I as I was growing up I
had this criss-crossing history of
mental illness in my family
schizophrenia and bipolar disease in
particular I had two uncles one with
schizophrenia and one with bipolar
disease they actually died living having
lived with that for many years one of
these uncles lived with my family while
I was growing up was very much very much
part of my family and then sometime in
my childhood my cousin again from my
father's side all the same sort of
family was also diagnosed and
institutionalized and that you know that
elephant in the room I suppose it's a
dried analogy for India but
that elephant in the room could not go
away would not go away you know like
most Bengali families my parents had
elevated denial to a museum great car
and but they couldn't deny it anymore
especially my father couldn't deny
anymore the idea that this was very much
part of his life mental illness the
heredity component of mental illness and
that's when we began to talk about it so
while I was in medical school while I
was writing in for a while I was trading
patients all of this history the story
was constantly in the back it was like a
buzz that goes in the back of your head
you know am i exposed and I vulnerable
who else is what does it look like what
you know is there a trigger that that's
needed that I had that that's missing or
present etc so this story was my story
long before cancer was my story what
became my story and in fact when I
finished writing Emperor of all maladies
I thought to myself maybe I won't write
another book I'll be done and then I
kept coming back to this idea you know
well this is this idea of and and as I
said it was like it was like Star Wars
it was like a prequel to the sequel you
you dedicate the book to two people
we're gonna get to one of them in a
minute but one of them was your own
grandmother yeah because she was
involved very much and taking care of
your uncles who were as you say mentally
ill and so there's a powerful story
there there's also a story I want you to
just read a little bit from the start of
the book where you were with your father
and you went to visit your cousin yeah
yeah I just read a little bit from that
just you know this is where the this is
where the story really begins
so this is actually just the very first
the very first this is the prologue of
the book it's it started families and
it's got a little epigram the blood of
your parents is not lost in you
it's got another epicondyle could read
the other program in the winter of 2012
I traveled from Delhi to Calcutta to
visit my cousin Moni my father
accompanied me as a guide and companion
but he was a sullen and brooding
presence lost in a private anguish that
I could only sense dimly my father is
the youngest of five brothers and Moni
as his firstborn fu the eldest brother
son since 2004 when he was 40 moaning
has been confined to an institution for
the mentally ill with a diagnosis of
schizophrenia he's kept densely
medicated awash in a sea of assorted
antipsychotics and sedatives and has an
attendant watch bathe and feed and feed
him throughout the day my father has
never accepted
moenay's diagnosis over the years he has
waged a lonely counter campaign against
the psychiatrist charged with his
nephew's care hoping to convince them
that their diagnosis was somehow a
colossal error or that Moniz broken
psyche would somehow magically mend
itself
my father has visited the institution in
Calcutta twice once without warning
hoping to see a transformed mone
living a secretly normal life behind the
barred gates but my father knew and I
knew that there was more than just a
Vonk euler love at stake for him in
these visits Moniz not the only member
of my brother father's family with
mental illness of my father's four
brothers - suffered from various
unraveling of the mind madness it turns
out has been among the mukajee's for at
least two generations and at least part
of my father's reluctance to accept
moni's diagnosis lies in his grim
recognition that some kernel of the
illness might be buried like toxic waste
in himself so that's the first paragraph
of the book so it's in it's in your
family you saw it when you were growing
up you heard stories about it
as I've reset your grandmother was was
very much an influential figure in your
life and you saw how she was toward your
uncles now they came to live with us
because he was not unknown able to take
care of himself
so in this nuclear family growing up
with the aspirations of a nuclear family
in Delhi was also present a remnant of
the past because both of them had moved
in with us by then and for you
years later as a scientist just the idea
that in your family you were constantly
right thinking about this in your family
it was one generation and the next but
it wasn't everybody in the family it
wasn't every cousin or absolutely I was
certainly not you but that's that was
the impetus that brought you to think we
need if you you wanted to spend more
time looking at the gene the genetic
mystery there's a connection to cancer
the first book but you really were
embarking on a completely different and
ambitious story that you wanted to tell
and and I did you know I assure a small
excerpt from this book in The New Yorker
on schizophrenia with the picture of me
and my father that was really the first
thing I ever I really wrote I sat on it
for many many years I didn't publish it
I didn't do anything with it but it's
the first thing that I wrote in fact was
the first thing that I wrote once I
finished Emperor and I wrote it
privately didn't publish it at all
didn't give it out to anyone it was just
part of my healing or writing process
and what's interesting but I went back
to it now that you know you're sitting
down he went back to it and genetics at
least it doesn't really rear its full
head in that in that little thing that I
wrote back then it's about family which
is why the prologue is called family is
the idea of genetics the idea of genetic
genes doesn't come into it it's a
reminder that you know we think of this
word gene and it's suffused our culture
and it seems to be sort of an abstract
concept that lies outside ourselves in
science you know people are talking
about in laboratories but family it
genes have to do with
family it has to do with us it has to do
with how you and I are made our you know
who in this room doesn't have a relative
who's affected by some illness which you
can ultimately track back to some
interaction between genes and and
environment so all of a sudden when I
look back at that at that little thing
that was more than prophets six pages or
seven pages I said to myself you know
this book is really this not good book
it was seven pages then this is really
about families it's about ourselves as
living organisms that emanate out of
these things called genes and that's
sort of the conception of the book you
you wrote this and before I ask you
about you know some of the history here
and some of the amazing figures you
write about you write this with a sense
I mean I get a sense of real urgency
from you that you felt it was it was
important to get this down now because
there's a lot going on in science and
you and I talked about this earlier
today you had a sense that it's really
important for people to begin to
understand themselves not to just leave
this up to the experts
uh-huh well let me just give you a sense
of what's going on in science and this
may help us have this conversation as
you move forward we're trying we're
learning to read and write the human
genome and I'm saying this very flatly
because I let me explain what what
reading and writing the human genome
means reading by reading I mean that you
know obviously may all of you know that
in 2001 2002 we obtained the sequence of
the human genome and by that I mean well
let's first define what the genome is
genome is the entire repository of
genetic information that is in your
cells that's in an embryo that's in
human embryos and it's written in just
four it's a four alphabet code a C G and
T so then your genome might read ACGT
CCC I'm making it up
GGG and not have memorized it TTT CCC
and so forth
but here's what's interesting about it
it this goes on in humans for 3 billion
letters and if you imagine it as
written as an encyclopedia this
encyclopedia would be 66 full sets of
the Encyclopedia Britannica
so it would line up all the edges of
this room and if you picked up 66 for
one of these 66 full sets of
Encyclopedia Britannica
it would read ACTG cccc TCC would be
inscrutable to you and me and yet here's
what's amazing about it yet out of that
seemingly inscrutable four-letter code
is built you and me then everyone else
in that room it's an astonishing fact
that that code becomes you becomes me
small variations in that code are
responsible in some part the difference
between you and me so going back now to
understand what we were what the
technologies are allow us to do number
one is that we're beginning to read that
code and beginning to and I should
emphasize very clearly that we're
beginning to be able to predict what
might be what or what might happen in
your future for some parts of that
genome just to give you one example if
you have the Braca one gene mutation
it's not a hundred percent chance that
you're gonna have breast cancer but your
risk of breast cancer may be ten times
higher than the and and then the women
who don't have that particular mutation
if you have a cystic fibrosis gene
mutation in both here both your both
parent land and from both your father
and mother
the chances are nearly a hundred percent
that you'll have that disease in your
future I could tell you that when you
were an embryo if you had the chase ax
disease mutation I could tell you from
your m but from your embryonic cell I
could tell you chances that you will
have that disease is a hundred percent
etc etc etc so that's reading the genome
and now we're getting to more
complicated things I could tell you more
potentially more complicated things of
our illness and people have started to
explore far from there but people have
started to explore not just illness but
I could tell you complicated things
about potentially our identity that's
already entering territory that we
should have some
moral concerns about that's one and
writing the genome means that not only
can I do that in just just reading it I
can actually go now and make directional
changes intentional changes in the human
genome using a whole new set of
technologies astonishing technologies
that we've hijacked from bacteria and
learn to use as humans and these
technologies allow us to go into that 66
volume inside of it again remember 66
volumes pick out one volume erase one
word in that encyclopedia put it back in
leaving we think we're not sure but yet
leaving all the other 66 volumes
untouched so it seems to me that once
we've acquired these technologies we
need to talk about them we need to talk
about them you need to learn about them
I need to learn about them we cannot let
this happen in the laboratory last week
there was a closed-door meeting at
Harvard where they proposed synthesizing
the entire human genome by stitching
together single sing single AC T G's
basically like a little bead on a string
in other words you could synthesize
technologies would soon become available
that you could take the entire human
genome and make it from scratch not a
science fiction/fantasy
we're not there yet but all the
technologies that allow us to get there
are being assembled and this is the time
to think about things this is the time
for me to think about mental illness for
you to think about whatever other
illnesses and mechanisms of variation
and identity that you may may be
interested in this is the time to think
about it this is the time to to converse
about it and if you don't we will give
this unbelievably important piece of our
history in our future
to people that we might not want to give
it to and you in the book among other
things you write about a period not so
long ago when the study of genetics was
heading off in a really terrible
direction and we know it led to some
pretty horrible things on this planet
but I want to touch I want you to go
back though to oh no
little bit of the history here because
you so much of what you just described
said it happened in the last 10 or 15
years or evening maybe last month but
you know you also you know it's humbling
to know that Aristotle was thinking
about this and that the information kind
of sat there and then it was another
couple of thousand years before or
almost a thousand years before Charles
Darwin started doing his work and then
after that some other really interesting
characters and you they're almost these
signposts along the way of people who
worked on genetics or worked on what
they may not have even known was
genetics but it all came together later
to be critical talk a little bit about
some of that early work that was done
people know Charles Darwin right but
well let's start I mean you know what's
interesting about it and certainly we'll
touch on Aristotle in a second what's
interesting about it is that of course
this is a perennial question I mean
since the dawn of human history you can
imagine one of the first questions we
asked ourselves is why do we look like
our parents or why do we why we not look
like our parents these two simultaneous
contradictions that yin and yang the two
strands as it were of these questions
have been part of our DNA cultural DNA
forever who hasn't asked that question
when an illness strikes a family we've
asked ourselves why they did not strike
my father or my mother why's it mine and
so forth I mean variations when
identical twins are born we say well why
do they look that the same and so forth
so Aristotle had a theory about this
Aristotle really began to think about
this very seriously and it's an
astonishing fact that in our struggling
was a was an okay philosopher but he was
a very good biologist which I've been
sure to say most people didn't realize
yes interesting what Aristotle at least
from completing him from my very
particular tinted lenses I see him as a
biologist completely I see him as a
philosopher only secondarily his but his
philosophy he really emanated out of his
desire to texana Mies to divide the
world up in different organic forms you
know what was form looked like what was
so Aristotle
realized he made the argument that what
was really moving what was really being
transmitted across generations was a
message was some kind of message and he
has knobbly phrase he said it's a little
bit like a carpenter shaping a piece of
wood the carpenter when the carpenter
shapes a piece of wood he was talking on
how organisms are form how human being
is formed he said when a carpenter
shapes a piece of wood he doesn't shape
it by by in a material way what he does
is he transmits an information as it
were through his handiwork or her
handiwork into that piece of wood and
that's what happens he's transmitting
information a message into that piece of
wood and that's what makes that wood
piece of wood acquire whatever form this
was back in you know I don't know when
don't remember exactly when I say I you
know exactly when that point of time
when he writes this but this was back in
the day when people were debating about
you know how gods gave us forums and so
forth so that's Aristotle and then
there's a long silence really after that
for a while people thought I'll give you
one more highlight memory and they'll
come to more modern characters for a
while people thought that this was the
greatest one of them all for all people
thought that in fact this was so
complicated they said why how on earth
can a fully formed human being an embryo
develop out of the unity never have been
when a when a woman conceives how can
that possibly happen and they made the
argument it was not been made in the
1600s then in fact a tiny miniature
human being was sitting inside sperm
right wrapped up like this and he drew
pictures of it too and and he thought
about it carefully then it had to be the
case that since that animal since that
homunculus as it was called would also
generate its own children a mini
homunculus had to be sitting inside that
homunculus right and so forth and so on
infinitely infinitely infinitely
miniaturized homunculus which was a
lovely idea of course
looking crazy if you think about it like
Russian dolls stretching out towards but
this was a this was one of the most
popular ideas about what how we
transmitted lightness which was of
course the center of the genie so so but
but the information but what he figured
out or what he thought about and shared
really kind of sat there as we said for
a couple thousand years along comes
Charles Darwin who did some important
work yeah in all this but then there
were some others who came along who
really were not appreciated at the time
one of them was a monk yes who you spend
I think some really interesting pages
yes
it's a fascinating story and so that's
Gregor Mendel Gregor Mendel really
launches the book and the modern history
of of genes and because Mendel realizes
mental perform Mendel's a monkey it's
very interesting that both Darwin and
Mendel are monks it's instructive about
our times that in the there was a time
that people have with spiritual lives
found no contradiction between exploring
the universe in its material form as
well as having spiritual life someone
should read Darwin and mental or force
people to read Darwin and Mendel I
suppose they've they've you know the
capacity and the compassion that they
brought to their and the passion that
they brought to that to their individual
scientific explorations was incredible
but mental fascinating character he was
a monk and he began to do extremely
simplified experiments that was his
trick he was a great gardener and his
trick his his main insight was to
simplify this this morass of ideas
around genetics you know homunculus is
sitting inside of oculus and he said I'm
gonna forget all about that in a second
at all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna study
with almost monastic concentration I'm
gonna study what happens to one or two
he actually said
seven individual features across
multiple generations of peas right here
were people are talking about you know
hugely complex experiments about human
embryology and how we were born there
was Mendel sitting in a small monastery
at the edge of the city of Bruno where
he said all I'm going to do is I'm going
to study seven captors I'm gonna map
them as they move he didn't coin the
word gene he had no idea what these
things were oh and at the end of it just
by mathematical reasoning he realized
that there has got to be something that
that units of information again going
back to Aristotle units of information
must be passing between the parent and
the officer and he was trying to
understand if he in fact he wanted to
work with mice but his superiors
wouldn't let him that's right because
because because mice was a little bit
too risky he's far away enough from us
but mice is a litter sky hello great
lovely story so I spent some time in
Mendel's monastery just it's a beautiful
place and one quick story and we move on
but um I went to Mendel's monastery in
Bruno and I travel in it's it's it's a
it you can get to it easily from Vienna
but it's a little bit of a slap so I've
traveled over to to Mendel's monastery
and I arrived there and I there was a
woman at the front desk and and I said
can I I've come all this way I want to
go and see this this mark the birthplace
of biology the place it was like a
pilgrimage for me and she said I'm sorry
you've to apply in triplicate the
monastery is closed so I said this is
the czech republic's so I said so I
pleaded I said I beg yes I have come
from all this way it's all I want to do
is I want to be inside I want to see the
library and she said no no you just sent
an application and I said well who do I
apply to and completely without any
irony she said to me
and so I'm from India and I said two can
play at this game so I said I hereby
apply to you
[Laughter]
and so she was defeated and she let me
so that was my trip to men's most
expensive you know I spent about four or
five days not in that you can't stay
there but I spent for five days going
back and forth being in the library
looking at that first garden where he
planted those peas that generated this
thing which is not taken over the world
and his what the work that he did wasn't
appreciated for a long time in fact it's
at obscure and he was scorned but at
some point somebody there were a number
of other important figures remind us who
came up with the term gene genetics so
it was somebody gets credit yeah that's
right there was much late again remember
men who doesn't even have that word is
vocabulary he knows that he stumbled on
something interesting notes what's
amazement mental is that once he stumble
he's like a he's like and he is go ahead
no go ahead because he fired up once he
had done yet this work was Sokka he said
his copies of his report he condensed it
went to forty some pages that sent it
out to all these scholarly centers but
it was just as anything no one said you
know this thing everyone said what is
this crazy monk writing about my he said
I should be reading this stuff and they
went on describing botany and physiology
and figuring out you know trying to
figure out how embryos were formed in
their very complicated ways comic
Ulysses falling into a monkey list and
so forth God knows but anyway but then
in the 1900s mental gets rediscovered
and soon after in 1909 we find the word
gene because botanists and ballads began
to begin to say to themselves we've got
to have a word for this I mean there is
this abstract we don't know what it is
we don't know what carries it it's a
molecule what what is it a structure in
a cell but something carries this
information we know it's important and
and so we've gotta have a word for it
William Bateson one of Mendel's great
defenders I talked about him he's a
there's a great picture of him in the
book coins the word genetics from genus
generation genius all of these words
coming together
in that in that word and so he coins the
word gene or genetics and then his
colleague Johansen says you know that's
the discipline genetics is the
discipline it has to be have to name
that thing and so they named it the gene
gene and and they're the work so its
fits and starts I mean there's progress
and then there's a setback and more
progress and and you do an amazing a
wonderful job of bringing to life these
people who really probably led pretty
extraordinary lives they were is stuck
in a lab or in an office somewhere
writing and and and working but and then
you you fast-forward to the 1950s to
Watson and Crick but before you get to
that point you know things really go
badly off track why did that happen how
did that happen so it's important to
remember that there's and it's important
to remember that off track because while
the gene is being explored
scientifically the study of heredity of
course has a long history and the desire
to manipulate heredity is not you can do
a really parallel studies and it was in
England that coincidentally in fact
Darwin's cousin Francis Galton
invented the term eugenics Gorton didn't
know very much about genes actually he
had a terrible theory of genetics
themselves they've made a mistake it was
kind of homunculus funnily enough the
mathematical monkey was I talked about
it in the book but we'll we'll set that
aside for a second but Gordon's a
fascinating character fascinating
character he was a great mathematician a
great statistician but he also lived in
Darwin's shadow all his life I called
Gorton that you know he's slung between
Darwin and Mendel I mean can you imagine
these two giants and you're supposed to
Gordon was supposed to be an epic giant
himself he was a child prodigy and tried
of course had many important
contributions to statistics and
mathematics but golden coins this term
eugenics because he thinks that
regardless of what the gene is whether
there's a gene or no gene we can use
human heredity by manipulating her
we can make better human beings and
Galton's proposed a coined the word
eugenics good genes eugenics in order to
try to make better human beings he
thought that if we breed selectively
breed the best human beings we will get
ups appear with emancipate ourselves and
here's what's astonishing which I
discovered is that this was considered
an incredibly progressive idea like
taking evening walks or you know getting
and getting constitutional baths and
spas and so forth this was considered a
very healthy idea for humankind and many
progressives some exceptions in some
notable exceptions actually many
progressives said this is a great idea
we should do more of this and so that
was golden and it took off in England
and stayed in England and that idea then
metastasizes and reaches the shores of
this country where it mingles with a
kind of Yankee practicality and becomes
it morphs into not just let's breed the
best
let's sterilize those who are under
carry bad genes which ultimately sort of
escalates slowly and leads to a case
that many people know carry bucks case
carry buck was a woman who was accused
of having genetic imbecility and
sterilized on that pretext and famously
the Oliver Wendell Holmes the so-called
great judicial moderate the case climbed
to his court and he said three
generations of imbeciles is enough and
carry buck was moved to a state colony
it was called then and she was forcibly
narcotized taken to an operating theatre
and sterilized on that pretext and there
was no real evidence that she had any
mail no books have been written about it
and there's basically no evidence that
she she was she was if anything she was
a you know she was a she was she was a
bit of a rebel that was the worst of her
sinners and you you were saying to me
earlier today that you felt it was so
important and you she's one of the two
people you dedicate the book to it was
so important to remind everybody that
this is happening that this happened it
it's not just Nazi Germany yes where
things just finish up that story thanks
for catching me be it metastasizes again
and then moves from selective breeding
to selective sterilization to selective
extermination and that that is that
that's the that's the final incarnation
that's the file in the macabre
incarnation that eugenics takes which we
now remember it by remember nazi of
genex you know beginning with people who
had again mental illness
moving on to things like depression and
ultimately moving on to the racial and
ethnic and human cleansing that the
Nazis brought to their full macabre form
and I put that right in the middle of
the book in fact I wanted to start the
book with with that idea just that but
then I realized that that the order to
start the book actually with the with
with with the
with attempt in German episode but I
realized that it's much much more
chilling to watch it happening in your
own in front of your own eyes that this
that the road to that Menace the wrote
that ghastliness was paved in
progressive by progressive feet by a
desire to indeed a desire to emancipate
the desire for perfect ability the
desire to make ourselves better ends up
in less than 30 years in the
extermination of someone who has a mild
form of mental illness I think we all
want to believe that that could never
happen again
but as you said a moment ago because of
the incredible advances that have just
been made and made in such a short time
that people really still don't
understand what do you think the
possibility is that that decisions could
get made right now or in the near future
that not not a repetition of some of the
the worst of what you described but we
could head off in a direction that it
might be very hard to turn around and
other kinds of examples and and they're
relevant today I'll give you one local
go so one example in the United States
and one example from internationally I
think I think that I personally think
being
having read this story I think it's very
unlikely that we will have a
state-mandated form of eugenics in the
United States in the future I don't
think that's likely I think what's
interesting and what's much more much
much much more much more difficult to
contend with is that we're entering an
era of personalized eugenics in which we
can can sequence this was going to be
this is this technologies available
today very soon you should be able to
sequence and people have done this
already in other countries every single
gene of your unborn child and the
question need to ask yourself is what do
we do with this information well you
won't know what to do with this
information unless you know what genes
are and how they interact with what they
produce so that's that's of course one
arena that it's important but meanwhile
let's not forget that the largest
numerically the largest eugenics project
is already going on in India and China
in some parts of India there are 700
women to a thousand men in human history
that has never been this skew of gender
ratios that is a eugenics project let's
not make any bones about it that is it
this genex project fostered by science
beginning with ultrasound diagnosis
ending up with you know amniocentesis
and gender diagnosis through chromosomal
analysis etc ladies I mean you know you
welcome to a dis genic well it's already
we already part of it and it has
destabilized societies there it has
destabilized the way we think about it
so it's not someone else's it's not some
other words problem this is our words
problem and the faster we accept it and
the more we understand it the more armed
we will be enabled to mitigate against
its effects internationally it's a it's
clearly a case of the science being
ahead of where governments policymakers
are are prepared to make decisions but
how much of that is is a practical
effect right here in the United States
right now I mean you talked about you
talked a minute ago
said about the work that's being done to
edit
than what you just said about creating a
person synthetically creating a genome
how you know how much de scientists talk
about that and you're a scientist
yourself how much decide to sit around
and worry about that think about it I
know how much do they talk to
policymakers well they think a lot they
worry a lot about it but the
policymakers don't have the language to
understand what the implications are
often in fact the scientists don't have
scientists don't have the language at
all there's an important meeting which I
described in the book that happens in
Asilomar the famous Asilomar conference
when actually the my my mentor for many
years Paul Berg I've worked in with Paul
for many many years we're still very
close friends Paul and several others
two or three other scientists discovered
the technology to cut and paste genes
together this in the 1970s you want a
Nobel Prize for this and essentially
it's relatively simple technology it is
you take one piece of DNA and you cut it
up using tiny molecular scissors that
are made by bacteria to kill each other
and you stitch them together with
another enzyme another factor which is
used normally when you're when your DNA
strands break because of x-rays say
something needs to stitch them back
together to maintain their integrity if
you just combine these two little pieces
these two pieces you can suddenly start
taking a gene from a frog
and stitching it together with a gene
from a virus you can take you can take
two genes of any sort and this is of
course incredibly important technology
the cancer drugs are made this way you
take it because the genetic code is
uniform and universal you can take a
gene from a blue whale and put it into a
monkey or a monkey cells and the monkey
cells will recognize it for all intents
and purposes as if it was a monkey gene
and make it as if it was a monkey gene
that's because we are all evolved from
the same original organisms and we share
the same genetic code so when this
technology was first created scientists
got together and
create an open meeting at Asilomar
journalists came bioethicists came
policymakers game they all spent months
reading there was no document about the
gene but they all spent months thinking
about the you know date collecting all
information that they could learning the
vocabulary and and then they had a
meeting in which they said we're gonna
put a voluntary moratorium for one year
that last will be longer for one year
before we can figure out what the next
steps are because this technology may
unleash biological cat catastrophe so it
is possible I think at least within the
United States to put moratorium on
things before we figure out what to do
what they mean in fact about two weeks
ago or two months ago there was a large
conference in which they suggested that
there should be a moratorium on editing
human genes in particular kinds of cells
certainly not every cell but embryonic
stem cells of certain kinds although
that's unlikely to happen but but
certainly human em human human embryos
meanwhile just to finish up meanwhile
there's an experiment in China that was
published where they went ahead and
tried to make a Jeannette defined
genetic gene editing in a human embryo
and there were non viable embryos but
they tried 76 embryos I think to try to
make it define genetic change and what
what happened what was a result well the
results we don't know fully the results
because it's you know if they were it
was there was published a little
piecemeal and again there were non
viable embryos so but the quick answer
is that in principle they could make
genetic changes in human embryos and
what does that mean I mean what that
means that in principle you could if you
tweak the technology if you do quite a
lot of tweaking but if you tweak the
technology you could say to yourself
that I'm interested in and I talked
about how you might tweak that in in the
real world
the Chinese experiment is actually not a
great way to do that experiment but if
you tweak the technology you could say I
want to remember try to erase the Cystic
Fibrosis mutation from my genetic
heritage I'm gonna try to erase the or
change a mutation or a variation that
causes the Alzheimer's disease
from my heritage and in the bizarrest
scenario you could say I want to add
information back to the human genome
which you could do you could add
information to the human genome we want
to make people taller or something again
again to remind us so and I talked about
this it's very important realized
tallness or height is certainly genetic
but at least five or seven genes govern
that could you change five or seven
genes maybe you can maybe you could
change five at least now we're changing
one but but but also as I said you can
add information back to the human genome
that that is a that's a surprising thing
we shouldn't we should take that very
very very seriously we're gonna be
taking questions from all of you in just
a couple of minutes but before we do I
want it I mean just how do we make sure
so be thinking about your questions but
how do we make sure that this kind of
work goes in the right direction and not
someplace that we don't even want to
think right well I think there has to be
an international consensus the national
consensus won't help because the next
thing you know there's gonna be an arms
race China Korea India will make start
making genetic interventions in an
actually outline one possibility one
kind of thought experiment you know
there's a famous thought experiment that
happened when the when when the atom was
being split you know long before the
atomic bomb was made there's a famous
letter that Z lard and Einstein wrote
saying you know there's no such thing as
the atomic bomb but here's a thought
experiment us think us walk just in your
brain walk through this process and you
land up with the unleashing of immense
power in a in a concentrated manner and
uncertain even writes to Z large and say
si the president says this could create
a weapon of great destruction
nothing's been made yet it's just that
you can walk the physical the mental
steps to it so I think we need to walk
those mental steps first and figure out
what the realm of possibilities is and
we need to walk those mental steps
internationally so that we can figure
out again what the realm of controls is
and I actually have since I suggest a
kind
framework by which we can we hopefully
with it where we can stick to before we
enter an era that we don't want to enter
so we're gonna take questions and I so I
guess there are a couple of microphones
before they come to the mic said you
know when I when I think about what you
do and I think about the book you wrote
on cancer and the work you did with
public television with Weta and I should
say Sharon Rockefeller here who's the is
here who's the president of WETA who
worked with you on the Ken Burns film
around and Ken Burns around the Emperor
of all maladies and I and I think how do
you even have time to sleep because you
are a scientist you're an oncologist you
write books you're a husband and a
father and you have a life how do you do
it all you know this book came out of
such urgency that it had to be written
I'd sort of prioritized this book over
everything I'd say took five and a half
years so you know it seems as if it came
up one morning but it took five and a
half years it took a lot of time and it
spent a lot of time on it and a lot of
it was going back to these stories I
thought to myself if I can just knit
together the stories one after another I
would achieve I would achieve the book
it's uh it's kind of extraordinary that
he could get her all done alright let's
start over here and I can't see very
well but step up to the mic and ask your
question hi my name is Andy and I'll be
starting school in the fall to study the
intersections of epigenetics and
anthropology and just had a question for
you regarding kind of along the lines of
this discussion of exploring new
frontiers of science um so I know you
drawing upon some of the work that
you've done on the tire you've written
about them epigenetics I think we're
starting to find a lot more information
and evidence about the in generational
and transgenerational um like
transmissions and inherence of
epigenetic information and I was
wondering in the spirit of this
conversation about understanding the
ethical and social considerations of
scientific findings what those would be
for an intergenerational invention yes
those let me rephrase the question of it
is a very important question the
question is to what extent so we know
that genes transmit information across
generations but lately there's been a
lot of interest in finding out whether
your things that happen to you in the
environment can also be transmitted
across generations the evidence for that
I think is very very minimal right now
it's a totally unexplored frontier the
famous experiment of course was
Weissman's experiment in which he
dismembered that it's a group gruesome
experiment but he dismembered the tail
of one generation of mice and he waited
for the next Mouse to be born and it
grew perfectly intact tail and he made
dismembered that and the next generation
was born for tail and he kept doing this
for multiple generations and not even
one centimeter of tail was lost so we
know that you know as significant a
trauma as it were as having a part of
your body cut off in the case of that
mass of that poor Mouse does not
register across multiple generations it
does not get transmitted and yet we also
there's some Inklings that for instance
starvation the starvation response
creates changes that are transmitted
across multiple generations in my in
ways that we still don't understand it's
an entirely new frontier and of course
it challenges the classical model of how
genes transmit information and we're
still trying to figure out what the
world you know what what is it what is
what is really what is the information
that's being transmitted what's amazing
about it and I think I'll just finish
with its idea what's amazing about it is
that genes actually protect us from that
genes were almost designed to wash away
the sins of our ourselves and our
fathers we reproduce an opposite in all
the scars and things that we have in our
body are washed away and a baby is
formed a new it's a very beautiful thing
that that is a very beautiful solution
to regeneration but there is evidence
now from again very detailed studies on
starvation and and other in simple
organisms that seem to have
some effect across generations we have
to find out more about it we're gonna
have to find us somewhat more cheerful
aspect genetics yes sir thank you my
name is Scott and I you know for years
we've had this dichotomy between
genetics and the environment what causes
social behaviors even from sociobiology
and I and I've always thought that this
is a false dichotomy and since that
everything is genetic and everything
also is influenced by the environment
and really the question is not whether
it's something is genetic or
environmentally caused it's whether or
not how malleable it is can it be
changed you know having poor eyesight is
genetic and yet we can do LASIK surgery
we can wear glasses and it doesn't
affect our behavior it doesn't affect
our our genetic fitness whatever so
really it's a it's a false question and
I was hoping I might actually I think
it's not not just a false question I
think it's a question that's led us in
the wrong dress in long riksha now let
me tell you what I think about it and I
write about this in the book extensively
what my thought is that when someone
asks the question is it nature or
nurture its engine genes or environment
the first question we should be asking
back is what are we talking about what
what aspect of human behavior of ology
are we talking about I'll give you some
concrete examples gender anatomy the
anatomy of gender is strikingly genetic
there's one gene that governs for the
most part gender anatomy if you have it
on it happens to be on the Y chromosome
unsurprisingly if you have that gene you
will have one particular Anatomy of
gender and all the physiology that goes
along with it if you don't have that
gene you will have a different Anatomy
of gender and all the physiology that
goes along with it how do we know this
because if you have if you have some
some women in inherit the X Y so they
are chromosomal email except that one
gene is mutated and if you mutate that
one gene these women are self-described
as women they have most of their gender
in Arabic intact they they're often
diagnosed as a syndrome called Swire
syndrome and they're diagnosed because
they are
in fertility so gender Anatomy
strikingly governed by genes gender
identity on the other hand is a complex
mixture we know that
so the idea and I talked about these
distinction in the book so the idea that
that now we've made a kind of armistice
between genes and environment is
actually fools armistice
there is no armistice it depends on what
level or what what what level of
hierarchy you were examining it depends
on the question you may examine and it's
it's amazing to me that in this culture
in 2016 the human mind is not capacious
enough to understand this simple idea
that some things can be strikingly
dominated by genes some things can be
strikingly dominated by environments and
some things live in the middle it
depends on what we're asking about so
thank you for saying thank saying that
thank you yes
would you please elaborate on the recent
developments in treating cancer with
gene modification particularly breast
cancer yeah so the the right now where
all of these technologies and this goes
back to the point that we're trying to
make all these technologies can have
very powerful effects and a lot of
promise so one of the things that the
brain cancer one is the one that comes
very quickly to mind there's a couple of
very recent important and potentially
striking trials of gene therapy and
brain cancer using various genetic
therapies to treat brain cancers
certainly in the LGB uh you know the
idea of genes being used in breast
cancer has a rich history starting with
diagnosis
Braca one in bracket two were identified
genetically years ago and have really
changed the lives of women who have
happened to have that mutation Herceptin
that antibody guess how we make that
antibody the only way to make er ceptin
as an antibody is to take a human gene
for an antibody and put in it in a cell
using that same technique that ital
talked about paul bergs and others
technique and that's the only way you
can make Herceptin so when you talk
about genes in cancer they run the gamut
from diagnosis to genetic therapies to
the creation of new drugs we would not
be here in cancer today were it not for
genetics and genetic engineering in
particular thank you how much promise do
you feel there is in that area again it
depends on which which arena I mean
certainly with you know antibody
therapies for cancer are one of the most
striking therapies these days so we are
doing more and more we're using them
more and more again would not be
possible without genetic engineering
genetics was used to figure out what an
antibody was in the first place you
wouldn't know what an antibody was how
your immune system worked if it wasn't
for genetics so genes underlie all of
these all of these really miraculous
advances yes the most obvious example
you know remember this distinction in
breast cancer between ER and PR you know
we talked about er PR guess what those
are genes estrogen receptors a gene
progesterone receptors a gene if it it's
a marker for for certain kinds of cancer
and if he would didn't know that we
wouldn't know how to treat cancer breast
cancer with tamoxifen and the doctors
physicians have had to learn this very
quickly absolutely you have to learn all
that genetics very very quickly yes
thank you what do you make or how close
do you think we are to potentially
getting into here for cancer and do you
think efforts like the president's
cancer moonshot and others by Sean
Parker another Silicon Valley folks are
trying to kind of get toward it here how
close do you think we might be so cure
is a complicated word in cancer because
it depends on the kinds of cancer that
we're talking about it has a very rich
history detailed in another book
that if you ask me about what I think
all these moonshot efforts I think
they're helpful in some ways and they
can be hurtful than others I think
they're helpful because they refocus our
attention at a time when our attention
span seems to have degenerated and we're
talking about what I think are rather
irrelevant issues when we when when
they're very clearly focused issues that
what you're talking about how to
emancipate our health problems how to
help ourselves how they help the economy
and so forth and so rather than focusing
on things that are not constructive I
think they allow us to rebuild faith in
in in systems whether they be federally
funded whether they be philanthropic be
funded they rebuild faith in systems
that can provide medical transformations
so I think that's very helpful the the
flipside of course is that that creates
a certain cycle of hope and hype and
people say these they've not met their
you know technologies are not ready yet
they haven't met their goals I think the
I think the I think the moonshot will be
partially successful because it'll allow
us to clear out some cobwebs that have
gotten in the way of of advanced medical
advances around cancer I think there
will be a backlash as well you know ten
years from now we'll be sitting in this
room and saying how dare we have said
you know that there should be a moonshot
for cancer
I think cancer is will advanced is
significantly in the next decade I'm
confident of that
thank you okay yes we have time for two
more questions okay thanks
hi we've been talking mostly about like
human genetics but when it comes to
policy and science being sort of ahead
of policy my first thought goes to GMOs
yeah and my understanding is that
there's a huge gap between what beasts
what is the scientific consensus and
consensus and what the public perception
is yes so I was just curious in your
work you know that to be honest I was in
this book because I really think it
deserves a full second book I like I'm
not going to write it
[Laughter]
the the the issue of genetically
modified organisms what I do though is I
talk about the technology is to create
transgenic organisms extensively in the
book but I don't go into the pros and
cons and the pluses and minuses of
genetically modified organisms but in
brief what I would the one thing I would
say is that our sophistication in being
able to create these organisms is
increasing daily and that obviously
raises the specter of unintended
consequences in the in the greater
biosphere I'm actually less concerned
about the unintended consequences on
human health locally I'm more concerned
personally I'm more concerned about the
greater unintended consequences in the
biosphere at large which is a much much
larger concentration which we could have
another time but the important topic
okay we won't count that as a question
we'll count that as a as a lead unto
another conversation so we'll take two
more questions almost identical okay
yeah okay thank you yeah thanks
all right okay hi my name's Alison
Burrell I'm a graduate student finishing
up at the National Institutes of Health
and recently I've gotten interested in
science policy and one of the questions
that you had asked was how much do the
scientists who do the science talk to
the policymakers and you had responded
something like well the scientists talk
science and the policymakers how
government and they don't really
communicate very well but you do a great
job and lots of other science writers do
a great job of translating that that
really difficult science talk into
understandable media and so I was just
wondering if you ever get the
opportunity to to talk to policymakers
and participate in that I personally I
do
I'm in Washington a lot I've been to
Congress several times particularly on
cancer in fact we screen part of part of
Ken Burns film in Congress so I I do I
think the problem is not the problem is
not that there isn't meeting spaces or
meeting opportunities the problem is
that the vocabulary is different
and once the vocabulary becomes common
once we talk about the same things it
actually becomes much much more easy of
course to have the conversation so part
of the effort I think here is to is to
at least arm ourselves with little
cavity so that when you open the
newspaper and someone says you know
someone's trying to synthesize the human
genome at least we understand what that
means what is the human genome mean what
does it mean to synthesize the human
genome what its implications down the
road and then we can have a real
conversation so thank you for reminding
us that that's the kind of effort that's
that's ultimately have for we need to
have the vocabulary as it were right
thank you okay last question
well my name is Marcel originally I'm
from the Czech Republic so I understand
what it's like let's have a drink a very
simple question your opinion do you
think that in the future we'll be able
to find smaller particles of genes and
for example identify genes that define
happiness and since we are in the
synagogue genes of spirituality these
are very interesting and complicated
questions and and and ten years fifteen
years ago someone would said those are
crazy questions but 15 years later
they're not so crazy questions actually
talk about this in the book a lot are
their genes for temperament are their
genes for personality etc almost always
these things are very higher-order
principles as it were they lie in
intersections between genes and
environments but do I feel that some of
these evanescent qualities have
some components of genes at their core
the answer will be yes and how do we
know that that the answer is yes because
very very detailed Studies on identical
twins separated at Birth separate was a
famous study which I talked about a lot
in fact I interviewed the one of the one
of the authors of that study for this
book
he's identical twin separated but
brought up in very different
circumstances share surprising kinds of
behavior they share personality traits
that you wouldn't imagine would happen
by random chance they share preferences
anxieties now what does that mean that
means that there must be things in the
genome that predispose us to certain
kinds of behaviors temperaments
anxieties etc what's also interesting is
that if you look at not identical twins
but siblings that number falls
dramatically what does that mean that
means that if you scatter genes around
you'll lose that effect it's a very
artificial defect so it is
simultaneously true that they're
elements in the genome that may govern
more complex evanescent traits of human
personality and that we it's unlikely
that we'll be able to manipulate them
very easily because there are multiple
genes that are that are that are
governing this might make the
distinction in the book between the idea
that these are in heritable but they're
not heritable it's a great question
thank you very much I think yeah we're
gonna help this story but we're gonna
have to stop I just want to say again
said it's a it's a it's a fascinating
book don't be intimidated by the fact
that it's about science because you
write it you write it it's about people
it's about family it's about it's an
it's just done in a remarkably
approachable way and it's a wonderful
read and a great book thank you so much
so it's been my pleasure thank you
[Applause]